[Music]
in a perfect world we would all complete
our jobs perfectly every single time but
mistakes are bound to happen at some
point and people all over the world have
managed to mess up some of the most
easiest tasks if you're new to our
channel don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we'll be showing you ten hilarious
pictures of people who had one job but
failed miserably you'll never guess how
one company screwed up a roll of toilet
paper
watch until the end to see their epic
fail and don't forget to leave us a
comment to let us know which of these
fails is the most hilarious to you how
do you spell stop the worst stop might
be one of the easiest words to spell in
the English language it's just four
letters long how hard could it be well
judging by this photo it's a lot more
difficult to spell than we thought even
though a stop sign with the correct
spelling is standing right there in
Clearview a city worker still managed to
spell the word wrong he had just one job
and he completely failed at it bridge
failed
depending on the size length and
complexity of a bridge it can take
contractors a few years to complete it
can you imagine working so hard every
single day to finish a bridge and as
you're putting the finishing touches in
place this is what you see this bridge
isn't even lining up which will make it
impossible for it to be finished as
contractors look at the blueprint to try
and figure out what went wrong the rest
of us are sitting back and laughing
hysterically if demolishing the bridge
and starting from scratch isn't an
option what would you do if you were in
this situation let us know in the
comment section down below a useless
mouse a computer mouse requires a soft
and smooth surface in order to function
properly the makers of this Apple Mouse
obviously didn't take that into account
when they were designing this product
the placement of the plug on the bottom
of the mouse makes it impossible for
anyone to use it what a waste
a cup of handle this right here is a
fail of epic proportions
instead of placing the handle of the
coffee mug on the outside of the cup
where it belongs the makers of this mug
placed the handle on the inside we're
not even sure how this happened at some
point wouldn't someone have realized
that the handle was in the wrong place
where
truly baffled painting lines when it
comes time to painting lines on the road
most cities will set up cones and place
notices on walls and trees so that
residents know which areas to keep clear
but the driver of this Jeep obviously
didn't get the memo
they left their vehicle parked on the
road on the same day the street lines
were being painted
instead of possibly towing the car so
they can finish their job the city
workers just continued painting the
lines right on top of the vehicle can
you imagine how TechEd off the driver
was when he went outside and noticed
these yellow stripes on his car we're
sure they went ballistic I can't handle
this anymore we thought changing a door
knob was a pretty easy thing to do well
we guess not
this person put the handle on the wrong
way and now this door will be left open
forever if this homeowner paid a
contractor to put the handle on
incorrectly we really hope they were
able to get their money back
Batman's makeover Wow we had no idea
Batman had a makeover
we're obviously kidding but we can't
stop poking fun at this hilarious fail
the children's backpack has a picture of
Superman on it but the words on the
bottom say Batman this would be so
confusing for a child but we're sure
plenty of adults got a good kick out of
this mistake how many holes when you
purchase toilet paper or paper towels
there's a hole in the center so you can
place it on a roll in your bathroom or
kitchen but only one hole is required
not to the makers of these paper towels
need to be fired there are actually two
separate holes in the center for no good
reason at all someone failed geography
okay we admit we've fallen asleep a few
times in geography class but knowing the
difference between Asia and Africa is
something most people are well aware of
or so we thought this t-shirt proves
someone definitely needs a refresher
course on all the continents because
they label the shirt Asia when it's
clearly an outline of Africa if you saw
this shirt on sale would you purchase it
as a joke or just laugh and walk away
let us know in the comment section down
below
wondering I this dull face is so scary
and it all has to do with a major
mistake made by the toymaker as you can
see one eye is perfectly fine but the
other eye and eyebrow
like they're running away from her face
we would definitely buy this doll as a
gag gift for an adult but we're sure
many kids would have nightmares if they
were to see the dolls wandering eye this
toy maker definitely failed at one of
the easiest jobs ever
which of these hilarious photos made you
lol - Mo's leave us a comment down below
and the most original comment will
receive a reply from the choco if you'd
like to see more videos like this one
please hit the thumbs up thanks for
watching
[Music]